Welcome to the Wildcard Club!
Hello, my name is Amelie and I am one of the captains of the
Wildcard Club.
Hi, my name is Rin Penrose and I am one of the captains of
the Wildcard Club.
Hello, I'm Iron Mouse and I'm one of the four captains of
My name is Jokey Bird, I'm one of the captains of the
Wildcard Club.
It's really nice to meet you guys.
I think it's gonna be such a fun club.
I'm very excited to meet some new people I was a bit
confused because no one ever asks me to join on things.
They never chose me for the sports team at school.
What's going on?
Oh my god, I was like, you with responsibility?
Is that going to be good or bad?
I was like, I'm going to try my best to be the best captain
that I can be.
No!
Mouse, are you done yet?
I'm not done yet.
Oh wait, wait, can I say one more thing?
I want to hang out with you.
Please come by.
Please join the club.
Yay!